[Music]
Universal Brotherhood.
Okay. Chinese. Chinese. Okay.
Yeah.
Uh I think similar question was asked
yesterday but I I don't I'm not so sure.
I can read it to you. He's saying his
name is Rico. He's an entrepreneur and
he's from a tongua uh clan from the
Chinese community in Indonesia and he
feel u you have read surah hujat ayat
number 13 it talks about universal
brotherhood. However, as a Chinese after
embracing Islam he feel discriminated as
the Muslims treat him as lesser Muslim.
So he feel this is a common issue in you
know in in in in his locality. How could
you advise and how could you uh advise
to overcome these kind of uh situations?
>> No, this is a question on the topic. It
wasn't as yesterday.
>> Sorry. The asked that alhamdulillah he
is a Chinese revert Muslim coming from a
particular clan and after he accepted
Islam when he heard my talk on surah
chapter 49 verse number 13. in my talk
brother
about he said that he's being
discriminated
because he's a Chinese so what should he
do
>> brother those Muslim who you are meeting
who are discriminating you are not good
Muslims
>> oh
>> if I come to know you are a non-Muslim
except Islam I will love you more
and I love you brother
>> oh yeah oh yeah
>> I will love you more than a normal born
Muslim.
>> Oh, thank thank you.
>> Mashallah.
>> So would you prefer me loving you?
>> Yes.
>> So what you have to understand those
people who have lack of knowledge they
will do that for me mashallah Chinese
Muslim m I'll be more good with you more
happy so that you stay in the deen. So
why should anyone discriminate you?
Because you are a Chinese. Why? That
mean these people who you say are
Muslims who are discriminating you. They
do not have proper knowledge of the
Quran.
>> And this is common even in India. There
are certain villages who believe oh we
are superior. We are say we are shy
and not shake.
>> I told you very clearly this full verse
says the only way you can be superior to
the other is by tawa.
If someone discriminates you because oh
you are an evil person, you keep on
cheating, you keep on having alcohol,
you keep on gambling, then okay, then
acceptable.
But just because you're Chinese, someone
discriminates you, that means there's a
problem with him.
>> Do you understand? So you have to feel
sad for them. You have to pray to Allah
that may Allah give them haya.
>> So next time they say something, you say
Dr. Zakai and inshallah most of the
Indonesian know me. Not all Muslims. The
doctors architect loves me because I'm a
Chinese.
>> Yeah.
>> And generally I will love you more than
the other one Muslim because you're a
new one. Correct.
>> Correct. Okay.
>> So I don't mind you hating me because
your knowledge of Quran is less. If he
hates you only because you're a Chinese,
he has a problem. If he hates you
because you are doing something haram,
that's different. You understand? Now
>> yes, understand.
>> And only way you can be a higher Muslim
is by having more tawa.
praying not only five times praying
praying da giving more charity this
makes you superior so
you should actually do dua for these
Muslims Allah hadik Arabic may Allah
give you haya
>> Allahik sometime it becomes like an
abuse
>> if he knows Arabic oh he so you have to
say may Allah give you haya
>> may Allah guide you
>> yeah only because you're Chinese.
They're saying like that. So it is
because of ignorance, because of lack of
knowledge. They haven't read the Quran
with understanding. They haven't read
the Quran with translation. So you have
to thank Allah. At least he guided you.
Correct. Correct. Correct.
>> So we thank Allah that Allah has guided
us. These people born in Muslim family.
They don't understand the Quran. So you
are a better human being than them. Hope
that answers the question. Thank you.
in
>> once again I would uh
>> by the way I love Dondi more because
he's Chinese
even Dondi I love him more
he's he's Chinese so he's more close to
me may Allah give him that and may Allah
inshallah inshallah give him more
strength so that he gets the other
non-Muslims to the de
>> amen for part